bonsoir alexis kohler merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france grosse journée on l'a
vu pour olivier vers en audition de mise
la santé à l'assemblée et au sénat grand
oral sur la stratégie sanitaire du
gouvernement olivier ferrand qui s'est
défendu de tout cafouillage l'on doute
de navigon pas à vue a martelé le
ministre de la santé
oui alors c'est une drôle de l'image
qu'il a utilisée parce que vu de loin on
a l'impression d'être en plein naufrage
sur un radeau un bateau ivre dans le
brouillard
alors on navigue pas vu mais on sait pas
si on n'est pas loin du cap de bonne
espérance ou pas loin des 40e rugissants
puisque tout est finalement la
transparence tant promise elle n'est pas
là elle arriva alors sur les doses
évidemment il a fallu beaucoup de
patience pour arriver à savoir enfin
combien de personnes sont vaccinées
mais malgré l'accélération de cette
campagne de vaccination
la france reste dernière durant avec 140
milles vacciner je crois c'est très peu
et le variant angles air de ce virus qui
est beaucoup plus contagieux qui est sur
le territoire déjà beaucoup et on a
l'impression qu'on nous ménage pour ne
pas dire plus tard qu'il va falloir
encore confiné chaque semaine c'est la
même chose c'est pas chaque jour c'est
la même chose mais c'est toujours à peu
près la même séquence conseil de défense
puis jean castex qui parle on va encore
avoir ça cette semaine on a l'impression
d'être enfermé dans le film un jour sans
fin
toutes les semaines c'est à peu près le
même cirque qui se répète avec les mêmes
cafouillage avec les mêmes scandale
aujourd'hui on l'a vu un devant les
députés les réponses de libérant et est
peu satisfaisante
oui il dit faire confiance aux
entreprises privées pour ce qui est de
la prise de rendez vous pour la
vaccination
ce n'était pas le cas rappelez-vous en
mars lorsque nombre d'entreprises
privées avaient appelé le gouvernement
pour commander des masques pour aller
plus vite lorsque les cliniques avaient
demandé à faire partie du dispositif là
il n'était pas question de travailler
avec le privé or maintenant voilà qu'on
donne deux millions d'euros par mois à
des cabinets de conseil comme mckinsey
voilà qu'on fait confiance aux
entreprises tant mieux
pour celles qui vont pouvoir organiser
la logistique mais ça veut dire quoi que
l'état est incapable que les
responsables sont irresponsables et
qu'ils ne savent plus quoi faire donc on
navigue peut-être pas vu mais alors
j'aimerais savoir si on est ou pas en
plein naufrage et puis c'est un discret
qui viennent des conseils de défense on
a l'impression qu'ils aimeraient le
maquereau est de plus en plus en colère
qu'il tousse la haute autorité de la
santé à la faute en lui mettant la
pression pour que la vaccination
arrivent plus vite quitte à faire fi du
consentement de la consultation médicale
donc ça avance au niveau de la
communication et encore mais sur le plan
vaccinal on ne sait toujours pas où on
en est et une communication alexis
resserré autour de trois ministres
précisément oui alors seulement trois
ministres vont être autorisés à parler
après les fameux conseil de défense
outre jean castex le premier nice on
aura olivier ferrand ministre de la
santé ça c'est normal gabriela talent le
porte parole et puis ami espagnol n'a
fait à l'industrie qui vont nous
expliquer doctement quelles sont les
lignes de paroles qu'ils auront appris
sagement parce que on a vu dans le
cafouillage des ministres qui sortait
des chiffres du chapeau sur le nombre de
vaccins d'ici la fin du printemps sur le
nombre de doses sur le territoire donc
pour éviter tout ça voilà ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir parler et puis il ya quelqu'un
qui a totalement disparu du dispositif
sans doute n'avait-il pas les faveurs du
président c'est alain fischer le
monsieur vaccin qui était censé
coordonner cette campagne massive de
vaccination
on l'a très peu vu depuis qu'il a ce
rôle parfois on l'aperçoit un dimanche
on l'entend au détour d'une radio de
plateaux télé et puis il disparaît et là
il est totalement hors du dispositif on
a l'impression que c'est vraiment la
république en marche qui reprend la
communication et pourquoi parce que
c'est un enjeu de taille pour emmanuel
macron si cette campagne vaccinale est
un échec comme l'ont été les masses que
les tests comme toute la halle la
stratégie sanitaire est est un échec
alors pour lui c'en est fini la
politique il ne pourra pas se
représenter en 2022 devant un bilan
aussi catastrophique donc aujourd'hui
deux choses rattraper l'allemagne ne pas
être le dernier élève faire tout pour
que les français aient confiance et elle
se faire vacciner en comptant sur le
nombre de français qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner avec cette nouvelle
technologie de la rn
évitez surtout une pénurie parce que
qu'est ce qui se passe là encore le
gouvernement fait comme en mars et il ya
un an
il gère la pénurie n'y a pas assez de
doses donc même si les français avaient
envie de se faire vacciner en masse ils
ne pourraient pas parce qu'on a des
problèmes de logistique nous les
cabinets de conseil et des problèmes
d'approvisionnement
donc ça reste épineux ça reste dangereux
et ça devient politiquement explosif
alexis un mot sur toutes les lèvres
évidemment que l'on craigne ou qu'on le
souhaite un troisième confinement est ce
que la france peut-elle en vivres à un
autre alors économiquement
psychologiquement un troisième
confinement et ce serait catastrophique
ce serait peut-être même
contre-productif et le début d'une
révolte contre cette folie sanitaire qui
rend les gens fous et qui met l'économie
à néant
on a des chiffres terribles qui viennent
d'études qui parle de 75% de restaurants
qui ne pourraient ne pas rouvrir le
monde de la culture le monde de la
restauration les stations de ski des
secteurs entiers qui sont à l'arrêt le
nombre de gens qui vont aussi se
retrouver sans emploi il y avait une
marche aux flambeaux ce soir à marseille
justement pour condamner les
destructions d'emplois et faire que si
on est capable de faire un plan
sanitaire alors il faut faire aussi un
plan d'urgence pour préserver les
emplois autant que faire ce peu c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire bruno le maire
selon ses dires mais je me demande quel
comment il arrive à faire des
projections tels qu'ils nous les propose
6 % de croissance pour 2021 il parle là
d'un défi mais c'est même pas un défi là
on est dans la folie ou bien il prend
des substances je ne sais pas c'est
incroyable de penser qu'un chiffre
pareil serait indéniable même au
deuxième semestre
donc on est dans la foi on est dans le
discours qui n'a plus rien à voir avec
la réalité et c'est grave parce que en
attendant les dettes s'accumulent et
faillite s'accumulent et on vous papa
qu'on va pouvoir redémarrer l'économie
parce que cette campagne de vaccination
ne sera pas non plus l'espoir tant
attendue elle va prendre du temps et le
vaccin on attend d'avoir un retour pour
voir s'il sera suffisamment efficace
pour contrer la propagation de cette
épidémie
donc rien n est sûr on reste
effectivement dans navigue à vue
mais une chose est sûre un troisième
confinement là ce serait extrêmement
délicat pour le gouvernement de gérer
cela et je crois que les mesures
sanitaires depuis le début
montré qu'elles étaient relativement peu
efficace que ce soit les masses que ce
soit les confinements il y avait les
gestes barrière heureusement qu'on les a
parce qu on parle de projection et non
on aurait eu peut-être les quatre cent
mille morts que d emmanuel macron mais
on attend de voir
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être efficace
alors est ce qu'il ne faut pas à ce
moment là un confinement total
une fermeture des frontières et le monde
qui s'arrête pendant un mois pour que ce
virus
arrête de voyager ça me paraît compliqué
personne évidemment ne souhaite une
issue pareil donc tous les espoirs
aujourd'hui on pose sur la campagne de
vaccination et ses désespoirs bien léger
ou d'un 3ème confinement clairement
c'est non merci alexis paulin